next sit in on a lecture of University
of Pennsylvania history professor Thomas
Childers his latest book is in the
shadows of war an American pilots
Odyssey through occupied France and the
camps of Nazi Germany this history on
book TV feature is an hour the first
glimmerings of that story came to me in
the spring of nineteen ninety two when
george allen a local Philadelphia man
approached me with an extraordinary tale
of an American pilot who was shot down
over France just after d-day hidden by
the French Resistance smuggled into
Paris where he was then captured by the
Gestapo taken not to a prisoner of war
camp but rather because he was caught in
civilian clothes with no identification
of dog tags was sent not to a poww camp
but the Buchenwald concentration camp
along with 167 other allied flyers from
there after surviving miraculously
several months in Buchenwald he was sent
to a poww camp in eastern Germany in
Silesia just in time for the Russians to
arrive in the Germans to empty out that
camp marched the entire camp of about
10,000 prisoners of war west into
Germany in front of the onrushing Red
Army they marched out in a blizzard in
the middle of the night most of them
miraculously surviving and then was
finally liberated in april by Patton's
army Roy Allen was his was george
allen's father Roy Allen had recently
passed away and George brought me a
scrapbook a lot of people have war
stories that they want to tell I'm
always interested in them I'm a real
sucker for anything having to do with
the war and experience of the war but
here was a man who arrived not only full
of the usual passion but with a scrap of
photographs photographs of the crashed
airplane his father's crashed airplane
of wheat field in France a photograph of
his father along with another Allied
airmen standing and civilian clothes on
the day they were smuggled out of this
little village you
Alicia tell into Paris in a whole series
of other photographs that were quite
striking I was taken with the story it
seemed almost incredible but I was
already working on something I was
working on a book which became wings of
morning about my uncle's air true the
last American crudely shot down over
Germany in the Second World War but
George Allen had given me the address of
Colette florin Colette flora ellos was
her married name her telephone number in
a village just outside of Paris and
after I had done my work in the area
around regensburg I found her up took
the train from Munich to pair us and
then on out to the little village of
julilah chatel where I met her it's a
tiny woman petite if she's five feet
tall she's standing on her tiptoes very
mistrustful in the way of the small town
French about this American suddenly
barging into her life to ask questions
about resistance activities and so on
she told me an incredible tale that in
the just outside the village British
planes just the land bringing supplies
radios smuggling British agents in and
out in small single-engine aircraft coli
Sanders it was a whole side of the war
that I had no idea of she was still
living in the village all the things
were still in place she showed me around
the field where the plane had come down
now the school where she had hidden Roy
Allen a tiny two-room schoolhouse with
her rooms above it that and the other
teacher the headmistress with her rooms
just above the school where she had
hidden this American for over six weeks
I was hooked spellbound by both the
story of Roy Allen which seemed to be
still highly improbable having written
about an air crew that had no luck my
uncle's crew here was a man who had
seemed to have passed through a series
of experiences that defied all sorts of
probability coming back I was able to
locate the surviving members of Roy
Allen's b-17 crew there were 10 min on
the crew that day nine survived only two
or alive at the time
I began doing the work I then went to
Germany to Boonton vault concentration
camp there I was able to look around see
the place is still there miraculously
one of the other prisoners who was with
him was another Philadelphia man named
Oren bowdern at was in California but
who had been on the same cattle car in
which Roy Allen had been shipped from
Paris to boot involve I was able to talk
to him I continued to follow leads I
realized that the head of the regional
resistance which Colette and Roy Allen
and the others thought was named Paul
guy ran and I thought just a local
regional resistance leader a brave man
turned out to be a man by the name of
Pierre mule song who had been trained by
the british soe and secret operations
had been parachuted back into france in
march of 1944 and had become an
extremely important resistance leader
the research trail didn't led me to
Paris where Roy had been taken he wanted
to leave the small village he went into
Paris as I said and was hidden by
resistance organization there he was
waiting to be put on what was called a
chain of evasion a network that would
take him out of Paris and on his way to
southern France over the Pyrenees and
back hopefully to England I found
through research in Washington and so on
we're the apartments were where he'd
been hidden in Paris I slipped into them
I was determined also to get into what
had been Gestapo headquarters at 84
Avenue fuch and was stopped it was
restrained at the last moment I think I
might have been the only person ever to
want to break in to Gestapo headquarters
in Paris and then as i said i went off
to spend more time and Buchan vault
where i was able to locate not simply
survivors but one of the men who had
in a block schreiber a man who was
secretary of a block who kept the
records for him he was a prisoner
himself but had kept the records for the
block in which one of weird pyramidal
salt was also captured and taken to move
in Vault had been hidden I spent
considerable time there for the
crematorium the main gate the guard
towers the torture chambers and many of
the other buildings still cling to this
haunted hillside above von maur it was
really a ghostly experience John Hersey
the Pulitzer prize-winning novelist and
journalist once observed that the task
of the historical novel he has and I
quote not to illuminate events it is to
eliminate the human beings who were
caught up in the events it is possible
in fiction to make reader identify
himself with the human beings in the
story to make the reader feel that he
himself took part in the great or
despicable events of the story
journalism allows its readers to witness
history fiction gives its readers an
opportunity to live in close quote
within the shadows of war what I've
tried to do is to turn her sees
statement on its head my goal here as in
wings of mourning is to illuminate the
great vents events of the Second World
War through the human beings that we
caught up in them to allow readers not
only to observe and analyze that
horrific conflict but to put readers as
it were in the action to allow them to
see it to smell it to feel it history's
mission is simon schama once noted is
and I quote to illuminate the human
condition through the witness of memory
and so the truths likely to be yielded
by such histories are in effect closer
to the truths of the great novels and
the great poets than the general laws
offered by ambitious social scientists
close quote having done my time with
quantitative methods and linguistic
analysis I'm not quite as negative about
what social science has to offer us this
shawna might be but I take his point
about illuminating human experience in
the past the story of Roy Allen Colette
florin p.m. you saw so powerful in human
terms seemed to me an ideal vehicle for
such a project allowing us to examine
day-to-day life in occupied France with
its intricate web of collaboration
accommodation in opposition as well as
the clandestine world of the French
Resistance of underground Europe and
especially the activities of the British
secret service SOE it's not really the
secret service but a branch of it as
well as finally then the nightmare world
of the Nazi concentration camps not the
great death camps in the east but rather
the camps that were established in
Germany buch involved a cow as ups and
housing flushing berg horrible places
are there on the right but not the death
machines of Auschwitz and the big camps
to the east in his account of his
experiences in the first world war the
British poet Siegfried Sassoon reflected
and I quote that remembering myself at
that particular moment he was talking
about nineteen fifteen sixteen i
realized the difficulty of recapturing
wartime atmosphere as it wasn't England
man a war historian would inform us that
the earlier excitement suspense had now
abated and the nation had settled down
to its organization of manpower and
munition making I want to recover
something more intimate than that he
wrote and so do I in the shadows of war
is not a novel it is not a
semi-fictional memoir such as sassoon's
memoirs of an infantry officer or Robert
Graves is goodbye to all that it's a
work of historical nonfiction it is
based on extensive interviews diaries
letters debriefing reports courtroom
testimony military records and
government documents in Britain France
Germany and the United States it also
draws on numerous memoirs and first-hand
accounts by survivors of the events
depicted here in researching the book I
have used the critical investigative
methods traditionally employed by
professional
but in telling the story I've relied on
literary devices more commonly
associated with fiction the events and
the people depicted in the book are real
and I've tried to present them as
faithfully as possible but with the
sense of immediacy and their own
inherent drama to do that I presented
the interrelated experiences of Roy
Colette and Pierre as they understood
them at the time knowing only what they
knew without the intrusive and I think
distancing presence of an omniscient
narrator the book is written then from
three points of view told with three
voices one is that of Colette the
schoolteacher one is p.m. you'll saw the
regional resistance leader trained by
the British and the third of course is
Roy Allen the American bomber pilot from
Philadelphia let me tell you a little
bit about the the actual story and give
you some sense of the flavor of what
I've tried to do on jun 14 1944 shortly
after the d-day invasion Roy Allen and
his b-17 were sent to bomb a aerodrome
German air drum just outside of Paris
they were hit they're not quite sure to
this day whether it was anti-aircraft
fire or whether it was a German fighter
plane in front of them blew up and Roy
and his crew bailed out the 10 min of
the crew nine of whom survived but came
down in very different places with very
different experiences one was shot as
parachute as he descended down to the
ground let me if I may read you a bit
and try to give you some sense of what
I've tried to do with the narration and
we'll begin first with with Roy Allen
who was in many ways typical of eight
their force the men and boys that flew
in the American eighth Air Force during
the Second World War they were
overwhelmingly young Roy was 25 10 25
when he was overseas that made him the
old man of the crew
it was an unusual crew and since that
four of them were married Roy was
married his wife was expecting back in
Philadelphia but let me give you some
sense of the flavor of his background
this takes place as they're approaching
the target on that day jun 14 1944 not
long ago Roy had been a freshman in
college struggling with calculus playing
football and baseball at Duke he had
never flown in a plane never even set
foot in one he hadn't had much of an
opportunity growing up in the only
section of Philadelphia lower only the
locals call it scornfully a
rough-and-tumble section of relentless
two-story row houses shallow porches
beer and chaser taverns trolley tracks
his whole world was all day Fisher Park
the fern rock and movie theater the
street corners and Stoops the house on
champ lust Avenue over his wife Mae
lived when they first met downtown
Philadelphia not yet called center city
downtown Philadelphia where his mother
worked as a legal secretary might as
well have been Zanzibar for all he saw
of it no one in the family had any
military connections in fact connections
of any kind his father had died when Roy
was just over one year old and his
mother did her best to raise him they
lived in a succession of cramped
apartments in the neighborhood mostly
second floor to room flats with thin
walls and cracked bay windows that
overlook the street money was always
tight he helped out working part-time
jobs full-time in the summers he learned
to look out for himself to improvise
sometimes he brought him slightly
spoiled vegetables from becks produce at
third cayuga where he hung out in his
spare time when things were really tough
he slipped a few models from the porches
down the street after being drafted he
applied for into his astonishment got
into the pilot training program went off
got his wings but just even when he
first got in an astonishing event
occurred he entered the program at the
Army Air Force training command at Santa
Ana California we are among other
wonders he was issued six pairs of pants
six shirts six pairs of shorts
undershirts a dozen pairs of socks two
ties two pairs of shoes a raincoat for
garrison caps
service cap with visor and assortment of
toiletries there was more closed and
ever owned at any time in his life for
as long as he could remember he had
washed out his only shirt every night
and washed out he shared every night and
warned his only other one the next day
at school he burned coats ties shirts
sometimes even shoes for any sort of
formal occasion proms graduation even
his induction into the Philadelphia
School boys sports hall of fame he was
quite a local athlete was asked by
Connie Mack to try out for the
philadelphia a's when he was still in
high school and the a's were actually
important in getting him off to to Duke
Boyd came down bailed out of his plane
got out landed in a tree as fell through
it and later on in the day having
avoided German patrols and the other
French police who were out looking for
him no friends of downed fliers he was
taken he ran across a young boy who took
him to a farmhouse and that farm has
turned out to be the parents of Collette
the local schoolteacher who was rumored
to speak English she did speak English
though when she arrived at the farmhouse
that night and got ahold of roy's I
always love saying this with my
Tennessee accent got ahold of Roy's
Philadelphia accent she couldn't make
head nor tail he didn't sound like the
the BBC announcers from the program that
she ordinarily listened to and when she
spoke English she still does to this day
I've interviewed her for over the past
10 years between her horrible english
and my horrible french she speaks in
language that is reminiscent of John
Donne so he's the sort of pre modern
terminology she was brought in to
translate and she it was decided that
Roy couldn't stay in the farmhouse he
had to be taken into the village there
were no Germans in the village they were
stationed nearby they were around so it
was decided that she would take Roy into
the village and that she would hide him
in her rooms above this echoes defeat
the girls school in the village her
rooms were a suite of rooms on the
second floor just across from the only
other teacher in the school who was the
headmistress name Madame Mademoiselle
belt so let me give you some just a bit
of of as they go back they go to from
the farmhouse in to the school Colette
sort explained to this strange guy from
this place called Philadelphia from a
strange with an even stranger address
2201 22nd hat a long series of numbers
which left her completely completely
puzzled there hi there looking in the
standing now just outside the school
standing in the shadows Colette wondered
if Roy Allen understood what she had
told him about the headmistress in the
school she had never known what to make
of Mademoiselle Baird they had lived and
worked alongside each other for almost
three years now and twice Colette had
hidden resistant in her rooms for
several days in november she had
sheltered to Gawler stage ins had people
working with the church Charles de
Gaulle's underground organization who
arrived by Lysander from England and in
February three more did Mademoiselle
Barrett suspect anything did she hear
them moving about in the little suite of
rooms just across from hers sometimes
Colette thought it was impossible that
she didn't know maybe she maybe she
believed Mademoiselle flora was
concealing her brother Andre or another
friend from the sto since februari 1943
when the Germans had initiated the hated
service due to elaborate waar many of
the people in the countryside had had
someone to hide a brother a son a lover
who did not relish spending the war as a
force labourer in the Third Reich
Colette was always careful in her
visitors from the resistance had been
extremely cautious during this day even
the girls in the classrooms below that
not heard them moving about Colette knew
nothing about med moselle Barrett's
views on politics on Vichy or the war on
anything except school matters like
almost everyone else in occupied France
the headmistress thought it prudent to
keep such things to herself a bit later
on Roy developed problems with his back
he'd hurt his back need crashed into the
trees but it also turned out that he
gallstones incredibly painful that there
was no medicine no way to treat it and
Colette was reduced to put pressing hot
bricks onto his back trying to keep him
comfortable and at one point his fever
shot through the roof and so finally
this is after weeks of hiding Roy she
decided that she would go across the
hallway to ask Madame Mademoiselle bed
for the thermometer collect did not wait
to concoct a story she crossed the hall
hesitated for a moment than tapped on
the headmistress's door I'm sorry to
disturb you she began but it's no bother
Mademoiselle Barrett interrupted she was
at all sharp faced woman it was already
dressed for bed cilla waited and
silhouette it in her flannel robe
against the light of her kitchen she
towered over Colette and are you all
right she asked bending slightly at the
waist as if speaking to one of the girls
oh yes I am Colette answered speaking
quickly sebab young Missy I am ok yes
I'm I'm but I am in need of the
thermometer thermometer might
embarrassed uh deed her for a moment
then person your lips she turned and
walked to the medicine chest beside the
sink voila she said returning to Colette
and handed her the slender boot
blue-lined case guess see Colette said
turning to go it's the American isn't it
madam pet said leaning into the dark
corner so into the dark quarter so close
Colette could smell the sweet tooth
powder celui que malad he's the one who
said Colette took a step backward and
blinked at the headmistress I she began
but could go no further Missy she
stammered out at last merci beaucoup and
began a retreat toward her room before
she reached the doorway the headmistress
stepped into the corridor tell him he
shouldn't sing so loudly she said one of
the things that Roy hiding in the
schoolroom Colette had told him you
can't make any noise it's not just the
Germans she was afraid I was also the
French and if the girls at the school
down below heard this man walking around
Roy Allen was well over six feet tall he
had size 13 feet nobody in occupied
France had she was that day they had a
miserable time try
to find them he wasn't supposed to walk
around he had a tendency to play the
radio in in the rooms up above so the
girls down below must have heard and Roy
Allen had a wonderful voice I've heard
tapes of him singing he had a wonderful
voice and he's saying so a bit later it
just after this the next day in fact
after the thermometer incident Colette
goes down to the school room but goes
down into the school and Madame it was
going to talk to to Mademoiselle Baird's
or to see what she was going to say
about this and the headmistress made no
mention of the thermometer or the
American or the singing she asked no
questions instead she rambled on about
the exams about school supplies for next
year about different girls and their
problems it was as if last night had
never happened so this is how she's
decided to play it Colette thought
she'll simply ignore it she would not go
to the authorities but she would not
help he was a shrewd calculation when
the Allies arrived in Julie she could
claim that she had allowed her colleague
to harbor and American at the school but
if in the meantime there was trouble she
would deny knowing anything at all about
Madame Mademoiselle flora and the
soldier the headmistress had been
discussing the math exam but this
Colette thought was the true moral
calculus of occupied France from from
huy Roy was taken into Paris but before
he went he complained constantly he
wanted to get to Paris he wanted to get
back to allied lines he told Colet he
maybe they could go as man and wife and
they would walk across France to
Normandy go through the entire German
army to link up with the Americans the
local resistance people were driven mad
by this guy and not only was he singing
playing the radio showing himself at the
window Colette came in one day as German
troops were marching by on the Rue de
fuss and there's Roy standing in the
window waving at them is
they went by and he was also insisting
that they get him out did they get him
back to allied lines back to England he
was also concerned his wife was
expecting a baby back in Philadelphia in
the meantime he did however meet the
regional leader of the resistance p.m.
young soul and Pierre was sort of sent
to talk to Roy basically to tell him
would you please be quiet would you
please sit tight don't cause trouble we
can't get you out just please be quiet
part of what you saw was doing was
receiving that night the British were
dropping supplies and large containers
machine guns food of all sorts supplies
of all sorts for the regional resistance
who were going to rise at a given signal
from the BBC to attack the Germans in
the rear as after the breakout from
Normandy and so mule song comes and sees
Roy Allen is also frustrated by them
sees that he's a brave man but is
mortified by by him let me give you just
a read a brief bit here about from
Pierre Meulens point of view and this is
where he is he's talking about her
thinking about the airdrops at night
these were very tricky things the BBC
would send a message or they would be a
Morse code message sent to the radio
operator of this little group there was
always a leader of the group a radio
operator and a courier the courier was
almost always a woman they can travel
around with fewer papers than the men
but an arrangement would be made and
then during the full moon there would be
parachute drops this was a really
dangerous thing because the Germans were
all around the planes would come and
drop these parachutes sometimes they got
hung up in the trees sometimes they
drifted too far and landed in places
they shouldn't but let me just give you
some sense of the flavor of that the
large cylindrical containers in which
the weapons and other supplies were
dropped we're heavy and unwieldy some
weighing as much as a ton the reception
committees that's what the group of
French on the ground recall the
reception committees
to work quickly to remove the outer
shell and in the field and disperse the
smaller more manageable canisters found
inside the canisters were then taken by
horse-drawn cart or more often by truck
to the arms depots which they where they
could be stored until they could be
distributed to the group's teams they're
all arms depots that they'd established
all around the area the containers
themselves would then be buried or
dumped in the nearby sin when April in
the first days of June the group
received over 100 containers and 12
drops Pierre had seen everything during
these nighttime opera nighttime
operations in tois nearby city he had
attended drops organized by the local
Gaul asst where as many as 30 people
were involved whole families might show
up to watch the containers drifting down
spreading picnic blankets in the field
at the edge of the woods this was not
good procedure and the british soe
didn't have anything to do with the
gawler snot for political reasons though
that probably plays a role because they
thought their security was bad it was on
other occasions the reception committee
would find itself surrounded by a ring
of cows surprised to find anyone abroad
in the moonlit field a huge white beasts
would lumber up to them and stay on
silent a spectres until someone chewed
them away in no time they would be back
materializing out of the wood line as if
conjured by a sorcerer once an enormous
wild pig it comes snorting and stamping
out of the underbrush scattering the
startled reception committee all over
the field burying the containers was
hard work and could take hours so
whenever possible the reception
committee bundled the empty shells these
things are over six feet long bundled
the empty shells into the back of betta
or ballad gays truck these are two local
resistance people and drove 25
kilometres to the bridge at Belvoir
where they slid them into the murky sin
they never encountered any trouble on
the road or at the bridge but one Sunday
afternoon is Bala gay and his wife metla
were strolling along the riverbank
downstream from the bridge they said two
young boys floating gately about in a
make shift boat as the boat drew near
the shore of the ballot gays stared in
horror boys were paddling toward them in
one of the
Shell's the containers camouflage
markings clearly visible above the
waterline after that the shore was
thoroughly searched for more containers
and they would never be certain about
the river again Roy Allen at this point
after having been interviewed by Pierre
mule song still insisted on getting into
Paris he was taken in to Paris where he
was hidden and was handed from one group
to the next and finally as he was
thought he was on the threshold of
getting back he was told he was going to
be picked up at this apartment on the
boulevard sebastopol the Belgian woman
who came to pick him up took him but
instead of delivering him to the
resistance contact she delivered him to
to Gestapo agents sitting at a cafe and
near the Opera and Roy Allen found
himself at Gestapo headquarters at the
Avenue fuch in civilian clothes no dog
tags no identification at all the
Gestapo agents roughed him up a bit
threatened to shoot him you're not you
know not an army officer and even if you
had dog tags it wouldn't make any
difference to us you're a terrorist pure
and simple and we're going to shoot you
a little later this went on for a couple
of days finally Roy found himself in a
large French prison and who knows what
might have happened except the Allies
were pressing in on Paris and the
Germans began to empty out the prisons
Roy and over a thousand french
resistance fighters as well as a hundred
and sixty-seven allied fliers who had
been captured in exactly the same way he
had and by the same double agent by the
way many of them were shoved into cattle
cars and went off on a nightmare journey
that took five days across France and
Germany over 100 people shoved into
these cattle cars meant to hold 40
people with one pail of water and
one for waste which were not changed and
arrived not at a poww camp but at a
place that the French people had heard
of and that was boot involved
concentrates he owns log of bluefin
level Roy Allen didn't know it but at
the same time that he was in Buchenwald
so too was Pierre Pierre mules saw the
regional resistance leader who had in a
completely unrelated matter been caught
by the Germans and had been sent by a
different route to boof involved they
were there at the same time Pierre moon
song would be executed one of over 30
british soe agents who were executed by
the Germans at the camp Roy miraculously
survived he had dysentery scarlet fever
dropsy pneumonia he lost a third of his
body weight during his months at
Buchenwald at a certain point the
Luftwaffe caught up with these allied
flyers took them out of the custody of
the SS and took them off to a poww camp
except that Roy Allen because of his
medical condition was left behind in the
camp twice when he really it was
remarkable he survived his feet but
drops his ankles were swollen his feet
enormous boob involved is on the side of
a mountain it's cold even in the summer
and there were no size 13 clogs his feet
for months on end were wrapped in
newspaper burlap and string for months
let me read one final passage here while
at booth involved Roy was forced to work
the concentration camp system in Germany
was for political prisoners who would
then turned into slave labor the Nazi
simply worked them until
and fed them virtually nothing until
they died of disease or collapsed from
one strain or another and then had new
people coming in let me give you some
sense of the routine this is after the
long appelles the roll calls in the
morning that would last hours or in the
evening of the last hours in the weeks
that follow this is after the other
allied Flyers had left and Roy was
virtually alone in bougainville his
routine very rarely varied he worked
outside every day sorting through the
rubble of the bombed-out munitions plant
just beside the camp moving stones
clearing debris aside from the midday
rations the only break came from the
increasingly frequent air raid alerts no
bombs fell on Google involved but the
warning sirens howl almost every day in
the men were expected to take cover
wherever they could on Sundays that was
entertainment the camp orchestra
performed classical pieces a Russian
choir sang and once a Ukrainian played
Slavic dances on his accordion a few of
the poles and Russians even danced
mostly though the men slim slumbered
through the performance is glad to have
an opportunity to rest during the day at
Sunday roll call the camp's brass band
played waltzes as a company meant to the
weekly hangings while the Blue Danube or
mentally from The Merry Widow slipped
gaily through the square a man his hands
tied behind his back in a block of wood
wired between his teeth stepped onto the
platform of the gallows well thousands
of prisoners all standing at attention
thousands looked on a noose was placed
around his neck and the steps were
kicked away and the man dangled beneath
the crossbeam writhing as he slowly
strangled to death on other sundays a
prisoner was stripped bent over and
shackled to a wooden rack and lashed
with a whip until the flesh from his
back and buttocks and legs was lacerated
into bloody strips of meat that
threatened to slip at any moment from
the bone punishment and SS officer braid
for anyone attempting to escape
meanwhile the band played on its
cheerful airs fluttering above the
horror like the butterfly over a corpse
it's hard to describe and I'm not
certainly going to try this evening to
describe the horrors of
the camp miraculously Roy Allen would
survive it would as I said find himself
at the poww camps dialogue moved three
inside leesia if you've ever seen the
old I guess it's now an old film The
Great Escape with Steve McQueen James
Garner and so on that's the camp though
in the movie it's set in Bavaria I think
and survived that all the way through
his capture from his days in the Paris
prison to train trip across Germany and
France to Boonton vault to the prisoner
of war camp he was tormented by the idea
that something he had done had tipped
off the Gestapo and that they had not
only captured him but also Colette in
the group back in juhi I think it's
probably fortunate that he never sought
pierre emile song in the camp itself or
he would have really I think that might
have been too much at the end of that
when he was liberated he was sent back
to camp lucky strike which was a camp in
France for American personnel returning
from europe he slipped away when a WOL
absent without leave away from that camp
made his way to Paris phoned up to find
out what had happened to Colette and
discovered that she was in fact still
alive had not been captured so what I've
tried to do with the book and this is
it's a complicated narrative is to weave
these three very personal stories
together as I said to tell us something
about the nature of life in occupied
France of what it meant the sort of life
and death in the eighth Air Force the
concentration camp system in a slightly
different life than we're used to seeing
it and then finally though I'm not
really talked about it the experience of
POWs that's what I've tried to do with
this book and with its predecessor wings
of morning
which represent the first two
installments at what is now evolved into
a trilogy on the war the last one of
which i'm at work on now that i'm going
to call the best years of their lives
about the difficulties of veterans
returning home from all of this at the
end of the Second World War thank you
Lysander is that the question was that
the plan on the the cover is a Lysander
it's a British plane I don't know any
other name of us it was developed by the
British for close air support of the
early part of the war but it was too
slow the Germans shot it out of the air
with frightened regularity and so it
turned into a plane it could take off
and land and rough terrain and bus
really that same plane could very well
be it was used all the way throughout
the war and we thought they had another
name for it not that I'm aware of guess
and when you look at this story from the
bottom up you see amount of effort that
the British put into this resistance
networking amount of
care and training can you say whether it
actually made any real difference
conduct of the war in France in 1944 did
the resistance actually into the Germans
a lot I don't know if everyone can hear
but the question is given all the effort
put into it by the British for
resistance activities and SOE did it
actually make a difference I think the
answer is actually yes there's a huge
debate as you probably know that there
are those that have argued that was more
effective than the bombing campaign that
is in the sense that it could target
specific targets less loss of life and
so on the way operations worked were was
that you know coded messages were sent
out by the BBC during these personal
messages during the French program every
evening that meant something to
different groups all over all over
occupied France they had specific d-day
targets and then follow up targets they
blew canals they were they were very
important especially in destroying
transportation access to the Normandy
beaches that was one of those as well as
the the air campaign aimed at this and a
great deal of disruption I think what
does it add to the overall outcome of
the war I think it was one of it was a
critical piece along with the air
campaign and then of course the invasion
and I what it's it's interesting as the
war went on there was a good deal of
competition between these groups as well
it was the Gaullist resistance there
were the the SOE and then there were the
Communists all of whom certainly wanted
to kill Germans and to bring the war to
us rapid and as possible but it didn't
want to cooperate with each other very
much certainly not at the highest levels
on the ground it looks somewhat
different and especially out in the
countryside where they really weren't
very interested in these differences yes
did you
show you how the captain Jacques was
able to infiltrate stay yes the question
is about someone that I don't think I've
mentioned here I mentioned the the the
double agent the Gestapo double agent
who was known around Paris as Captain
shock or shawl the Belgian I had several
different names he actually had had he
was from the area around lil actually
just across the border in Belgium had
infiltrated another group before this it
was known as el meson resurfaced and I
think the critical piece was and it
wasn't the only infiltration these
resistance circuits were broken all the
time the number of people that were
arrested and caught especially in these
chains of evasion the evasion circuits
because then you move people around and
once inside the key thing for him is
that he was able to make a link up with
this man named George provo who worked
in the prefecture of police who was one
of the major contact points for Allied
soldiers allied flyers really escaping
Jews as well but mostly allied flyers
and having made that breakthrough with
privo Prevot for months was turning over
allied flyers to this man the he knew
only as Captain Jacques and assuming
that they'd all they don't made it and
then there was this horrible moment for
Roy Allen standing at the prison as
they're getting ready to get on the
buses to take them really on their way
to Germany into an uncertain future and
he looked over and he saw privo his
contact man who was also captured and
was being taken this is one of the
reasons he thought they'd done the whole
the whole network it wasn't so in common
but this man whose name was disobey was
one of the most infamous of all and one
of the most successful of the double
agents there were two really famous ones
and he was one yes
research information salt because you
talked about three actually to talk to
collected and with reality probably the
American research
his covert operations the question is is
at the American side of this might have
been easy though I'd never met Royale
and Roy Allen died before I had a chance
to meet him how did I know about p.m.
you'll science activities in France well
the way I knew it was that he had been
trained in Britain there was a record of
his training through SOE this material
is not has not until very recently been
available I didn't get it in the
archives you have to go through the
Foreign Office they release it very very
in a very tight way now it's more now
dis increasingly open but a record he
came back after one mission he came back
and it was a debriefing for him for
Charles his radio operator and for me me
this wonderful woman who had who was the
courier for the group so they came back
there were long transcripts of their
their interrogations then after Pierre
and Charles had been captured by the
Germans Mimi survived as well as a
number of other people that were
connected with Paul and they were
debriefed back in London at the end of
the war so they were able to say this is
what happened this is what we were doing
this is what Pierre was doing this was
our plan then also in the French
archives there are obviously resistance
activities are not something that people
kept records of but at the end of the
war the French did a very good job of
going around and doing interviews and
having people talk about their
experiences with the resistance suddenly
everybody had been in the resistance and
there I was able in in the archive in
tois
to find several personal accounts of
interactions with Pierre mutant in booth
involved the night before he was
executed he wanted to see a priest and
he knew he had met someone from tois in
the camp who had any sort of religious
observance was punishable by death in
bougainville so it was a tricky thing
but there was a priest this man took
p.m. us on to the priest and that man
survived the war and wrote about it
there were a number of other people
prisoners who had been officials in the
barracks for Pierre middle zone was
housed who survived and left accounts of
him and these other 36 SOE operatives
and also witnessed his execution so I
would not have thought when I started
that I would ever be able to find this
kind of information and then at a
certain point once I got into the
British materials it just cascaded and
then there were all sorts of connecting
points yes
a lot of phrases and French and German I
was wondering how
no one of the things I tried to do
there's a lot of German there's a lot of
French in the book just little phrases
to give both flavor that's one thing but
more to the point of that is that one of
the I was struck by Roy Allen and
survived all of this was handed from one
group to another in France without
speaking three words of French and then
in boonton vault the prisoners were
polish Hungarian Ukrainian Russian
German and speak a word of anything and
so his whole Odyssey through all of this
meant that he was dealing with people
who did not speak English he didn't
understand what they were saying he was
having to sort of figure it out and I
wanted to put the reader into a position
where he or she would feel that same
sense of weight what's what exactly is
happening there's an incident in the
book that I talked about where he was
the resistance people in Paris got him
into a hospital this was an amazing
thing they had a resistance person who
was a doctor they got him in because his
back was horrible he thought he drenched
it somehow but it turned out to be gall
stones kidney stones and sorry I'm not a
painful painful so they and Roy is taken
into this hospital controlled by the
Germans with the French staff he's there
and all of a sudden this dog this guy
shows up puts him on to a sort of you
know wheel stretcher and takes him off
to this operating room nobody's in
surgical clothes nobody looks like a
doctor there's no sterilization of
anything and the guys suddenly shows up
with something that looks remarkably
like a catheter with sharp blades and so
on and decide to take to make a very
invasive sort of procedure he's supposed
to be a deaf-mute he's not supposed to
be able to say anything this was one of
the standard ploys for downed British
and American fliers during the war was
to be deaf mutes you wonder if the
Germans had been very keen about this
there must have been all these deaf
mutes
wandering around in occupied France so
he there he is and people are speaking
French to him he doesn't know did and
he's trying to say it's my back it's my
back it's not something else but and
then the next day the doctor sort of
comes into him doesn't say a word to him
and then finally before he leaves
basically says kidney stones and left
but that's why the phrases some of them
are translated some of Mahrt i think to
give that sense of what it's like to
have your fate in the hands of people
that you don't understand and don't
understand you yes can you tell us more
about his life after he returned to the
US and the next 30 years how much impact
yeah Roy Allen's experiences after he
came back well he was a remarkable man
in a great many ways he came back his
son had been born Roy jr. had been born
while he was in bougainville he came
back put together his had a family for
children successful career in business
in the Philadelphia area he he he didn't
talk a lot about his experiences during
the war this is quite typical I think of
that generation in general for years
after the war didn't talk about it and
then at about the time of retirement
then he opened up and began to talk but
I mean these are very personal things
but nobody in the family seems to
remembers him being having what we would
think of his post-traumatic stress
syndrome some of the book the survivors
from this allied flying room did have
that suffered greatly one Australian man
in particular so he picked up and went
on and only later in life did he began
talking about the Buchenwald experience
he didn't went back to schooi took his
wife may May in Colette have remained
friends over all of these years still
are in correspondence there was always I
think in these two families a slight
mystery because Roy had spent these sort
of six weeks and very close quarters
with this young French woman one of the
things that's very clear about this is
that Roy and Colette there was a very
strong emotional bond formed and they
remained friends and went back and forth
Colette still is very active
we spoke to her on the phone last
weekend but there was no this is one of
the things that's a mystery to me I must
say not the relationship but and this is
one of the reasons I want to write a
book about the experience of people
coming back because we have this sort of
notion now sort of greatest generation
notion which you know this is my parents
generation I'm I don't dispute any of
that and that's not what's not my my
goal in thinking about it but there were
so many people that came back that were
not Veterans Administration cases that
were not as suffering overtly from
post-traumatic stress syndrome but who
wound up with all sorts of adjustment
problems as they came back and that's
been kind of swept under under the rug
it seems to me and not in in other ways
in very personal ways my father who is
in the 8th Air Force had been married
for about a year went overseas to
England was going for two years no
telephone calls didn't hear his wife's
voice for two years they wrote but I
mean correspondents by vmail and the
regular males was slow and cumbersome
when he finally got back home in 1945
stood in line in newport news virginia
to to talk to her on the telephone when
suddenly here's this woman at the other
end of the line that he has my father
who had an even stronger a Tennessee
accent than I do and my mother had not
one as strong as his when my father put
all the rest of his life said you know
the only thing I can remember about that
conversation with your mother after two
years was what an accent that woman has
that sort of you know that that's not a
traumatic adjustment but they're all
these sorts of things of women who were
had gone into the workplace and then
forced back into the home and then of
men who were by day perfectly fine but
had all sorts of problems that were not
addressed in any direct wife yes um
she's very happy with it I gave her
chapters as so that she would see them i
said to her to Warren bout her to Joe
Bruce who was the navigator on the roys
plane I said if there's anything in here
that doesn't sound right even if nobody
will know what that you I want to know
what it is Colette certainly said no
this didn't happen this isn't the way
this looks you should do that and there
were things that I hadn't gotten right
the she she corrected she's very proud
of it she is is not hesitant to tell me
where I've gone wrong and she also would
give information and in little bits and
pieces I've dinner I started
interviewing her in 1992 and talked to
her a lot over these years and every
time there'd be a little more a little
more a little more and one incident in
particular I I asked her to describe him
what Pierre millstone looked like what
did he look like I'd never seen a
picture and so she tried to describe him
and I said do you have a pictures and no
nothing okay I go back and then in the
English files the SOE files I found a
photograph of p.m. you'll so so I sent
it to her proudly look here's a picture
pierre emile song she sends me back a
letter with another picture of pierre
emile song and says this one is better
uh so there is a small town French
mistrust of other people in town to this
day somebody denounced her anonymously
and as she said at one point I think I
know who it is person still lives in the
town i also told her after all of this I
said I know why the Germans never caught
you she was very very stingy with
information but loves it and that's
that's that's been nice it was very
interesting on one of the trips the last
research trip tying up the ends of the
book we spent time in England where I
taught to the best historian of SOA
Michael foot amardeep foot who himself
was in undercover activities not
necessarily a wonderful typical sort of
British public school oxbridge type guy
who was just if we were there on D on
the anniversary of d-day we had to stop
in the middle of lunch to have a moment
of silence at a toast he had come to
visit me here at Penn I'd gone down on
the street to meet him because I was
afraid you'd get he wouldn't be able to
find my office he didn't come I went
back up to my office which was lot open
the door and he was inside I said him I
know why we won the war we went from
there to to huy lesha tell and to this
small diminutive woman who was
incredibly brave who'd hidden American
flies not just Roy Allen but to others
and then from there went out to Germany
to vom our and up to Buchenwald and one
of the people I was able to find is
actually the block Shriver the Secretary
of the block repair moon song was a
prisoner he had been a communist most of
the most of the prisoner officials work
honest German Communist and he
remembered them
and but talking to him the steely steely
gaze he survived years in bougainville
where he couldn't trust anybody and to
go from one to be from England to France
to Germany and to talk to these people
who had first-hand experience of all
this was really extraordinary
well I hope so I hope so at this point
we don't know there's interested in in
Spain Italy the Czech Republic don't ask
they translated the other the other book
in Japan and in China and in France but
who knows what will come the bowl lab
but it would be nice i think for co
latin for her son jean-jacques to see
the story in French their photographs in
the book he didn't Roy Allen didn't have
the photographs Colette had the
photographs from France some of the
photographs from bukan vault I found at
the Imperial War Museum in Britain some
were at there is an archived and a
former SS barracks at Buchenwald where
there are photographs and sketch they're
wonderful [ __ ] well wonderful their
horrific sketches made by a French
artist named Gustavo VA who was a
prisoner at Buchenwald who sketched
individuals and scenes to do those
sketches no photographs were allowed
inside the camp you could not take a
photograph and these sketches were
illegal as well he could have been
tortured killed for doing it but these I
had the piece together Roy didn't happen
pictures they well I went to the you
know you applied for permission to use
the various archives and then you have
to get permission to use the photographs
a lot of the number of the photographs
that are in the book are in private
collections may Allen has some Collette
has photographs of her family that's in
the book and the boob in vault was the
the drawings and so on the the staff at
this bukan vault archiver very good sir
I think that would make a movie I don't
really have to answer that do I I'm
happy to have done the book one never
knows if something becomes the film I
think for the modern imagination of 2003
the idea that these this man and woman
could have lived for six weeks in such
close quarters and they're not have been
more than just this emotional bond seems
incredible I'm afraid to think what
would be and let loose
was that sort of thing would sell
tickets that's right Thank You Thomas
Childers is author of wings of mourning
the Nazi voter and his latest in the
shadows of warm it's published by Henry
holton company on the web at Henry Holt
com next week on his